situation in ukraine
and hmg supports the government in kiev
mr speaker the situation on the ground
is grave
as we can recall on the 24th of february
forces of the russian army
unprovoked crossed into ukraine
sovereign territory
along three main axises russian armour
has attempted to occupy ukraine
their plan was to reach and encircle
kiev encircle ukrainian forces near the
border and invade from the south to link
up with their forces via mario pole
russian high command had committed 65 of
their entire land forces and
indisputably are in possession of
overwhelming firepower and armor
it is estimated that at the start of
this invasion they had between 110 and
120 battalion tactical groups dedicated
to the task compared to approximately 65
in ukraine
their missile stocks gave them even
greater strength to reach ukraine at
distance
however what they did not possess and
still do not is the moral component so
often needed for victory
mr speaker after 14 days of the war
according to the ukrainian general staff
at the 6th of march russian casualties
were assessed to include 285 tanks
985 armored fighting vehicles 109
artillery systems
50 multiple launch rocket systems
44 aircraft 48 helicopters and 11 000
soldiers who have lost their lives
needlessly
there are numerous reports of surrenders
and desertions by the ever-growing
disillusioned russian army
but to be clear mr speaker these are
ukrainian figures and i have to caution
the house that we have not verified them
by defense intelligence or other means
of the initial russian objectives i can
announce the house that it is our
assessment that they have been
successful in achieving only one
and while russian forces are in control
of kirshon militipol berliansk in
southern ukraine they currently encircle
the cities of cherniv sumi kharkov and
mariopol but are not in control of them
in addition mr speaker their first day
objectives of targeting ukrainian air
defense has failed preventing total air
dominance
the ukrainian armed forces have put up a
strong defense while mobilizing the
whole population
president putin's arrogant assumption
that he would be welcomed as a liberator
has deservedly crumbled as fast as his
troops morale
for our part mr speaker the united
kingdom
continues to play a leading role in
supporting ukraine
on the 17th of january i announced the
house the government's intentions to
supply military aid to the ukrainian
armed forces
the aid took the form of body armor
helmets boots ear defenders ration packs
rangefinders and communication equipment
and for the first time it also included
weapon systems the initial supply was to
be 2 000 new light anti-tank weapons
small arms and ammunition
mr speaker in response to further acts
of aggression by russia we have now
increased that supply they can update
the house that as of today we have
delivered 3
615 end laws and continue to deliver
more
we will shortly be starting the delivery
of small consignment of anti-tank
javelin missiles as well
i want to show the house that everything
we do is bound by the decision to supply
defensive systems and are calibrated not
to escalate to a strategic level
britain was the first european country
to supply lethal aid and i was pleased
that not long after a military aid donor
conference i held on the 25th of
february that many more countries
decided to do the same
from right across europe the donations
came in particular i want to highlight
the netherlands sweden finland denmark
poland romania the baltic states belgium
and slovenia for their leadership and we
should not ignore the significance of
the german government in joining us in a
change of stance and donating such aid
donations mr speaker are not enough the
delivery of the age of the front line is
just as important
here again britain is leading because
alongside canada the united states and
sweden
we have invested in you building
ukrainian military capacity since 2015
and we find ourselves able to coordinate
the delivery alongside our partners
as the conflict intensifies mr speaker
the russians are changing their tactics
and so the ukrainians need two too
we can all see the horrific devastation
inflicted on civilian areas by russian
artillery and air strikes
indiscriminate and murderous it is vital
therefore that ukraine maintains its
ability to fly and to suppress russian
air attack
to date the international community has
donated over 900 man portable air
defense missiles
and thousands of anti-tank guided
weapons of varying types as well as
various small arms
but the capability needs strengthening
so in response to ukrainian requests the
government has taken the decision to
explore the donation of star streak high
velocity man portable anti-air missiles
we believe that this system will remain
within the definition of defense's
weapons
but will allow the ukrainian force to
better defend their skies
we shall also be increasing the supplies
of rations medical equipment and other
non-lethal military aid
as with any war the civilian population
is suffering horrendous hardships
according to the ukrainian ministry of
education
211 schools have been damaged or
destroyed and media footage shows
russian strikes hitting kindergartens
the chernov regional administration
reported that russian air force was
employing fab 500 unguided bombs against
targets in the city
and according to human rights watch
civilians in maripol have now been
without water and power for almost a
week
president zielinski talked of children
dying of thirst
today the estimated number of ukrainian
civilians killed or injured now stands
at over a thousand
the true figure is expected to be much
higher and i'm afraid worse is likely to
come
it is for that reason that the uk will
increase its funding for ukraine to 220
million which includes 120 million of
humanitarian aid
this will make the united kingdom the
single biggest bilateral humanitarian
donor to ukraine
we also supporting humanitarian work
with the polish and romanian
governments on the borders
as i said mr speaker my last statement
we still believe it is worth trying to
build diplomatic pressure on russia
this week my good friend the prime
minister met the prime ministers of
canada the netherlands and poland he
also spoke to the leaders of france
germany and the united states and prime
ministers of hungary slovakia and the
czech republic
the foreign secretary is in washington
at the g7 and also attended nato foreign
ministers earlier this month and i
myself only this morning met with
ukrainian ambassador
president putin should be and can be no
doubt that the international community
is a united against his actions it
remains strong and will not back down
as well as providing direct military
support to ukraine we continue to
bolster our contribution towards nato's
collective security
nato defence ministers will gather next
week in brussels to discuss the next
steps
the uk is doing it fit
in providing military support and
reassurance to its allies
we are currently supplying significant
air power to nato including increase in
air patrols with both typhoon
and f-35s under nato air policing
we have also deployed additional four
typhoons to cyprus to patrol nato's
eastern border and sent an additional
800 troops to estonia
over the last week apache and chinook
helicopters were involved in exercises
in estonia and meanwhile hms diamond has
sailed to the eastern mediterranean hms
thunderland is taking part in a northern
deployment and hms grimsby's in the
norwegian sea supporting nato mine
countermeasures
on monday hms prince of wales rfid targe
surge and hms defender joined hms albion
and rfa mount sprays on exercise cold
response a multinational
exercise off the coast of norway and hms
richmond will be exercising with our
joint expeditionary force
we have brought more than a thousand
more british troops on readiness to
support humanitarian responses in the
bordering countries
britain's contribution to nato is
significant and enduring it's important
at this time that in order to maximize
our reassurance and resilience effect we
coordinate through nato and the supreme
allied commander europe
few of us mr speaker will not have been
moved by president zielenski's speech
yesterday
his people are fighting for their very
survival
his country is united against the
aggression and it is indeed his
country's darkest hour
yesterday i saw footage of a russian
armored train bristling with guns
heading towards maripole
a brave
single woman from ukraine
ran to that train and shouted slavo
ukrainia
unmoved unintimidated by the guns the
woman's bravery should inspire us all
i know many of our constituents mr
speaker and our colleagues are fearful
of what happens next
president putin and the other and the
kremlin continue to threaten countries
who offer help to ukraine
their military campaign will i'm afraid
get more brutal and more indiscriminate
but mr speaker it is my firm belief that
our strength to stand up to such
bullying comes from our alliances
as long as we stand united both as a
house and as the international community
then the kremlin threats cannot hurt us
we should take strength from the peoples
right across europe who is standing
shoulder to shoulder to protect our
values our freedom our tolerance our
democracy and our free press that is our
shield